like you said there's so much of life in
the Amazon that we don't uh creatures
with no names
tons of them we could go out on a night
walk right now and I could show you
something that you know you I've done it
you you pick up a bug and you go
that doesn't look right
that's not right he's got three heads
yeah you know and then you send it to to
the the greatest expert on that genus of
insects and and they go look I got no
idea and you're talking to a world
expert and it's like that's it and then
50 of the life is up in the canopy and
so like we started climbing the trees
like rock climbing like what Alex
Honnold does like well like I'll climb
up 50 feet and then I'll put a safety
like I'm basically Trad climbing and
then I'll climb up another 50 feet and
I'll have JJ belaying me from below and
then I'll be like oh look a snake I'm
like JJ
pay attention like did you get up there
and the the branches are as thick as
this table so you can like walk around
freely oh it's like total like Avatar
when they're in the floating islands
like you can you can go run around if
that's what you want to do
bromeliads orchids cactuses because up
there it's against the Sun so it's a
different environment oh wow yeah
interesting
um and then you start seeing lizards and
snakes and birds and things that aren't
down on the ground
and so how many scientists have actually
gotten to really spend time up there and
really inventory the life that's why
when you hear about you like it it's
like a taxonomical discussion of how
many species there are on earth they're
like between you know 10 and 30 million
and it's like well that's a big
it's a big swing
what about stuff on the ground so you
mentioned some insects what about bullet
ants
so supposed to be the most painful bite
in the world you've been bitten by one
seven or eight times yeah what does it
feel like okay so the first time that we
ever did bullet ants um
JJ said you know okay this is what we're
gonna do he goes you know it's bullet
ant roulette we're going to get a bullet
ant and we get like Chopsticks you like
pick up this bullet ant and they're big
they're big and they're tough looking
he goes we're gonna put our forearms
together and we're gonna drop the bullet
ant and clamp our forearms together and
just rub and whoever whoever it takes it
takes yeah of course JJ did not get
stung and I did and it hurts every bit
as much as they say it hurts it really
let me have it and then and then I was
like hitting my arm against the table to
try and like kill it or get it off but
it was holding on and just like really
injecting the Venom
and uh yeah really letting you have it
and then it it travels up and it goes
into your like lymph nodes and and into
your here and you get a headache and and
I think the the the brilliant thing
about the
the the Venom of a bullet ant is that it
makes you feel like like this this
feeling of alarm it makes you feel like
something's wrong you don't just go ow
this hurts like it's like a bee sting or
you oh this really hurts on my hand it's
like no no no your whole nervous system
is freaking out and you start sweating
and then you get cold and then you're
tired then you get a little blurry
vision and it's like that's actually
that bad I mean now after six or seven I
get bitten and I'm like kind of okay so
it's a whole body full mind experience
it's a full body full mind experience
but then there's places in the Amazon
where they you know stick their hand in
a glove with like 70 of them right and I
think Stevo did that which I I would I
just don't understand how you could do
that without going into complete
anaphylactic shock and dying because one
really sucks
uh well it's just like just like we said
with animals and with humans there's
different kinds there's different kinds
definitely uh especially unique the
first of a species